- Did you say, did you
say that back to them?
(Jen laughs)
- You're talking in your sleep again.
(bouncy music)
- [Jen] Well, I am Jen.
I've been dating Steve
for about three years now.
I think he might be a little annoyed.
I've been recording you
and, like, putting them
up onto my Snapchat story.
- This is like blowing
my mind a little bit.
How long have you been doing this for?
(Jen laughs)
- Just like, six months.
- Six mo - six months?
Are you kidding me?
- There are so many funny things
that he says in his sleep.
Every day is a surprise.
- What time do you wanna go tomorrow?
- [Steve] She, uh, knows
that I don't use Snapchat.
I have one, but I don't really use it.
And she, basically it's the perfect crime.
- [Jen] I can't even comprehend
how some of the things he
says gets into his head.
- If it wasn't me, I'd
be laughing at it, so.
(violin music)
- Well, you wanna, you wanna watch some?
- Not really.
Are we supposed to go get the shot off?
It doesn't even sound like my voice.
What time do you wanna go tomorrow?
- I was trying not to share.
- When I say, "What time
do you wanna go tomorrow,"
- Yeah, what time do you want to go ...
- I'm always making plans
(Jen laughs)
in my dreams, apparently.
Apparently that's all I'm
doing, is making plans.
Oh no no no no no.
What time do we wanna go get the ...
(Jen laughs)
Same thing!
- Clean up.
- At least I look, like,
angry and confused there,
(Jen laughs)
like, what is this light
that is stopping me from making plans?
Apparently.
- [Steve] It's trippy.
That's the best word I
can use to describe it.
Trippy.
- Yeah.
- I'm concerned it's a crime. Right?
This is like a very,
- A low-level.
- modest, casual,
low-level crime, it's like
right below jaywalking, right?
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Right? So I gotta figure out something
that's equal and fair
in terms of retaliation.
- You still love me, right?
- I guess.
You gotta find the right
port so that it'll work.
(mumbling)
We should go to the store
so that we can pick up
the pieces of furniture.
I'm glad that you have zero to no remorse.
(Jen laughs)